est
ce que vous êtes venus ici aussi pour
surveiller les filles parce que pas mal
de miss qui traînent un peu partout sur
la croisette je ne surveille personnes
majeures animé l'enfant et le point mode
on n'a pas fait trois modes avec sylvie
tellier est ce qu'on peut savoir ce que
vous portez se sont alors ça sans rien
de changé si j'étais à la beauté et à
l'heure qui vous êtes et françois lucas
on s'échange combien de fois quand on
vient à cannes par jour x 3 points
2 - aller travailler
chaque rendez vous professionnel
l'après-midi une jolie pour la montée
une tenue classique et bien écoutez pour
l'instant cet instant côte mais on
attend la suite
[Rires]
[Musique]
c
go
ouais
et
when you realize that arabe
[Musique]
yann est situé à l'île de man fait rien
on fait l'amour ce soir inquiète alors
c'est l'histoire d'une bataille
[Rires]